The next question, my name is Arman. I'm
from India. My question is, Islam has
prohibited to shake hands with the
opposite gender because in Islam it is
prohibited to touch a namarum. So my
question is, can a man shake hands with
a woman while wearing gloves? Please
answer as soon as possible. The question
posed by Arman is that it is prohibited
in Islam for a man to touch a nam woman
and he agrees with it's haram. But can
he touch a woman after wearing gloves?
Means if you're wearing gloves, can he
shake hands with a woman? And we know
the hadith of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is very clear
that the prophet peace be upon him said
it is better to hammer a nail or a
needle into the head rather than touch
an The hadith is very strong. It's very
bold. It's very direct. It is preferable
to hammer a nail or a needle in the head
rather than touch a naman woman. So
therefore touching nam is completely
haram. It's not prohibited. It is
prohibited and it's not permitted.
Regarding the question that can you
touch a woman wearing gloves. Now there
are some hadith in which the prophet is
said to have shaken hands of ladies
beneath a cloth. There are a few hadith
but all these hadith is a they are weak.
There is no authentic hadith in which
the prophet ever shook hands with
ladies. In fact there are various hadith
of Aisha may Allah be pleased with her
who the wife of the prophet saying that
the prophet in his life has never
touched any nam. So based on this, it is
not permitted to shake hands with women.
Neither is it permitted to shake hands
wearing a glove because yet even if you
wear a glove and you shake hands of
course it's haram. There going to be
feelings. You cannot say nothing
happening to you. So it's not permitted
to shake hands with glove or without
glove. Both are prohibited.